kendall Jenner granted a temporary
restraining order against alleged
stalker Siobhan Mackenzie in docs
obtained by ET Kendall states as a
result of mr. Mackenzie's repeated
harassment and stalking of me I fear for
my life and have suffered and continue
to suffer emotional distress the 20 year
old model told police she came home
Sunday night and found Mackenzie outside
her house she claims she recognized him
from previous incidents of harassment
according to the police report Kendall
says the suspect followed her into her
driveway before she hopped back into her
car and called her friend legendary
music executive irving azoff that's when
Mackenzie allegedly started banging his
fists on her car when police arrived the
report says Mackenzie told them quote I
just wanted to have a conversation with
her but everything just went wrong if
she could just see what a chill guy I am
I know she'd want to be with me
Mackenzie has been charged with two
misdemeanors one count of stalking one
count of trespassing he's pleaded not
guilty
you